championne madame monsieur bonsoir
jamais le tour de france 2 les tenues
une telle crise révélation rock dandysme
en grand déballage se sont succédé tout
au long de la journée
le dopage est maintenant avérée et
avouée par les coureurs de l'équipe
festina la pression de devinettes énorme
sur le peloton au bord de la crise de
nerfs le départ de l'étape a été
différée de près de deux heures après un
appel à la grève en forme de révolte des
coureurs
nous nous traitent comme du bétail a
lancé laurent jalabert à l'adresse
pêle-mêle des organisateurs des
différents responsables et les médias
finalement le peloton est parti c'est le
belge tom steels qui l'a emporté à
l'arraché au cap d'agde alexandre kara
nathalie calais tarascon-sur-ariège
voilà une ville que le taux n'est pas
près d'oublier
au départ de cette 12e étape des vélos à
terre et pour le racing
je n'ai pas une chute une grève du
jamais vu sur le quai de france
thriller album les coureurs on nous
traite un peu comme du bétail y en a
marre de ces il ya eu l'attaqué sien
maintenant les couleurs la boue à la
limite c'est s'intéresse personnes vont
passer le tour va rentrer chez nous
était de continuer tout seul elle
possible de partir la course est
paralysé jean marie leblanc le patron du
cloud
avec laurent jalabert le ne reproduisez
de la révolte du peloton à ce moment on
peut craindre le pire aux passants qui
apparemment n'a jamais présenté mon cou
à quelques décisions que ce soit logique
le peloton on discute et toi tu
connaître contre lucie contre les médias
qu'il s'excuse de ne parler que de pages
on n'est pas concerné alors la moindre
des choses c'est de conserver les grands
leaders vite le temps est de trouver une
solution à toutes ces choses là et elle
finalement ou de la discussion
un règlement temporaire intervient jean
marie leblanc a menacé prendre des
sanctions
deux heures de retard pour une triste
état on devine ici je l'avais s'échappe
une brave and is it au sprint en style
lampe à huile ce soir sur youtube
personne ne parle de victoire à vrai
dire sur le tour beaucoup de coureurs on
refuse de nous parler et quand ils
s'expriment ils ont des regrets dans la
voix
c'est dommage que les coureurs n'est pas
été solidaire allait lui était le
porte-parole
à découvrir et puis à l'écran car les
chorales qui n'ont pas voulu le suivre à
ces dommages au terme de l'étape jean
marie leblanc au cours d'une conférence
de presse at il résumé l'état d'esprit
général sur le tour c'était ce matin
comment dire meurtri m'apprit que le
tour
pour l'heure rien n'est réglé les
coureurs devront se réunir ce soir pour
décider de la suite à donner
il ne sera plus jamais comme avant à
l'origine de la grève des coureurs de ce
matin leur colère notamment à cause du
traitement des médias en général et de
france 2 en particulier c'est ce que
vient de dire le directeur du tour
jean-marie leblanc
les coureurs ont été excédé je crois il
faut le dire par un reportage qui marque
et qui a été diffusé hier soir devant
nous dans le journal d'une grande chaîne
de télévision nationale
et ça a été la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase
c'était un reportage qu'ils ont
qualifiée et ne sont pas les seuls deux
poubelles au sens propre sens figuré qui
étaient tendancieux à leurs yeux
malhonnête et c'est la raison pour
laquelle choqués ils étaient ce matin
ils ont voulu se manifester je vous lis
de suite j'ai partagé l'irritation des
coureurs à la vue du reportage
dangereuse que j'évoquais à l'instant
donc s'il nous devions annuler cette
étape le tour 81,18 ne s'en remettrait
pas et les autres des années futures
aurait du mal à s'en remettre
jean marie leblanc vient de le dire le
principal sujet incriminés étaient de
notre confrère olivier galzi il évoquait
ce que l'on trouvait dans les poubelles
d'une équipe italienne
ça mérite quelques explications michele
finn dire que depuis quelques jours nous
avons nous avions des informations
convergentes qui nous permettait de
penser que dans les hôtels lorsqu'elle
quittait les hôtels des équipes les
siècles à l'intérieur des poubelles des
taxes dont le contenu pourrait être
intéressant alors ces deux cas c'est lui
notre journaliste se reporter sur place
olivier galzi il s'est rendu sur place
et il ya trois jours dans un hôtel
amendement il a ouvert la poubelle il a
regardé il a trouvé un sac avec à
l'intérieur une véritable pharmacie et
des produits très intéressants
il a découvert des médicaments interdits
comme le célestène crohn ou doses qu'il
est un corticoïde radicalement avec la
mannequin inflammatoire qui permet aux
coureurs de mieux supporter la douleur
et a découvert également des produits
qui sont des gros de produits qui
permettent d'accompagner le p o comme
des perfusion de glucose
tout cela il faut savoir que nous
l'avons vérifié nous avons pris deux
jours pour le vérifier auprès de
plusieurs médecins nous l'avons aussi
vérifier auprès d'anciens coureurs et
notre journaliste ensuite interviewé le
médecin de l'équipe qui était en cause
qui avait laissé sa poubelle dans
l'hôtel qui est une équipe italienne
alors aujourd'hui il ya polémique
est ce que parce que c'était parce que
notre reportage pourrait gêner peut-être
nous pensons en tout cas nous que notre
journaliste a fait son travail rien que
son travail il a fait quelque chose qui
se fait moins en moins de nos jours un
véritable travail d'investigation et
cette inertie les neuf coureurs et les
deux responsables de l'équipe festina en
garde à vue depuis 24 heures à lyon ont
tous été remis en liberté les derniers
en début d'après-midi les cas de dopage
des coureurs ont été avérés par des
prélèvements de cheveux et tout selon
nos informations on finit par avouer par
milieu richard virenque le champion du
monde laurent brochard ou le suisse
alexis soul à lyon bénéficie jusqu'au
bout une poignée d'inconditionnels à
vous de soutenir ses héros ils ne savent
pas encore qu'à l'intérieur des chars
vivre un cas vous pourrez toujours fous
ont les leurs les gens
enfin d'autres efforts d'autres
le avant 16 heures le voeu de se
supporter et en partie exaucé
suite à leurs aveux les derniers
coureurs toujours maintenu en garde à
vue sont remis en liberté la nuit
dernière après 10 heures de garde à vue
laurent brochard christophe moreau et
armin meier avait tout à chloé enveloppe
avant d'être libéré peu après à l'excès
ou le crack est à son tour le coureur
puissant aujourd'hui très choqué
moralement alex est détruit il a dit un
ami ne voulait plus continuer le
cyclisme professionnel et que pour lui
je crois qu aujourd'hui les coureurs
unanimement considère que pour eux la
décision de venir était la bonne ça leur
a permis de vider leur sac ça leur a
permis de crever l'axé et ça leur a
permis de chacun d'eux
au fond de l'eau de dire leur vérité
leur vérité les neuf coureurs l'ont
donné tous sans exception ont admis les
principaux faits reprochés à leur écran
le dopage est bien de manière organisée
chez festina la fameuse caisse noire
aussi seuls aujourd'hui la défense de
richard virenque peut encore sauver les
apparences et entretenir le hangar
d'après ce que m'a indiqué il n'a pas
reconnu passé d'aveux
parce que pour lui il n'est pas content
il s'est dopé
de toute façon ce soir la vague festina
se transforme en véritable raz-de-marée
de ces 24 heures d'audition les
enquêteurs ont retiré la certitude que
richard virenque ses coéquipiers
n'étaient pas les seuls à avoir recours
au dopage
selon nos informations les policiers
disposent aujourd'hui d'éléments
suffisants pour inquiéter d'autres
équipes parmi les plus en vue sur la
route du tour de france
parmi les neuf coureurs de festina qui
ont reconnu le dopage le suisse armin
meier qui a pris 2 le bo je me sens
comme une victime déclare pied ce soir
je vous propose de l'écouter
depuis combien de temps pensez-vous de
le pays depuis deux ans rédiger un
document les agendas des déclarations
d'il pas de mine les cheveux quand j'ai
su qu'ils allaient prélever des cheveux
du sang de bury nocives quand j'ai su
qu'il faisait des analyses
j'ai compris je me sens comme une
victime en sang
victime d'un système n'avait difficile
d'expliquer non plus si vous roulez en
convoi sur l'autoroute est limitée à 80
avait tout le monde commence à accélérer
90120 est le seul à vous faire prendre
et les autres continuent à s'en va les
traiter c'est mal après j'ai fait mes
déclarations ils m'ont descendu dans la
prison de ski j'ai dû me déshabiller
complètement
ils ont fouillé tout le corps et puis
l'ont envoyé dans la cellule
il n'y avait qu'une planche pour dormir
et puis je suis resté là quand je ne
savais pas combien de portes à lille la
confrontation très attendue entre les
trois responsables de l'équipe festina
ne semble pas avoir apporté de grandes
révélations le directeur sportif bruno
roussel et le soigneur vini brut ont
confirmé leurs aveux le médecin écrit
clark a assuré qu'il ne participait pas
directement au dopage les trois hommes
ont été remis en liberté parce qu'elle
dit c'est bon carline mars il n'a pas
envie de parler mais les voûtes a pris
une heure plus tôt sa mise en liberté
sous contrôle judiciaire
il n'a qu'une hâte à les retrouver son
épouse qui l'attend tout près dans un
endroit tenu secret le masseur a dit ce
qu'il avait pas d'idée et ses défenseurs
veulent maintenant lui et l'image
publique du délateur
il n'a pas dit le 100e alors ça je
m'excuse mais je pardonnais ma véhémence
depuis trente années qu'il exerce ce
métier
oui les gouttes et unanimement respectée
dans ce métier
donc il y aura d'être à mon avis oui
vous tient des carnets et il établit
alors au millimètre près à la seconde
près les agissements les trafics les
l'enrichissement générés par le dopage
depuis 30 ans dans le milieu du cyclisme
et croyez moi de tout cela monsieur oui
vous tapez a dit un mot voilà qui ne
manquera pas de faire jaser le peloton
ce matin la confrontation deux thèses
s'affrontent à celle de bruno roussel le
directeur sportif
oui les voûtes les cris d'une
organisation générale du dopage chez
festina à laquelle chacun prêté la main
face à eux le docteur éric ryckaert s'en
tient à sa version personnelle je savais
tout mais je ne participais pas on sait
maintenant quelles sont les positions à
la fois d'une coupe d'un côté de vivre
et de bruno roussel deux autres vérités
retour et bon vent n'y a guère plus
aujourd'hui c'est pas l'instruction
c'est 17h15 croire que beauté sur sa
position il s'en va beaucoup modifier sa
position si oui les bunds retrouvent la
liberté
mais vous savez les crickets en revanche
restent en détention provisoire
le juge d'instruction pourrait entendre
les coureurs dans les semaines à venir
les affaires de dopage sans doute avoir
des prolongements chez les cyclistes
amateurs en poitou charentes 135 de paix
ont été dérobés il centre hospitalier
universitaire de poitiers en novembre 97
et juin 98
tesla pour alimenter des marchés
parallèles ont fait privat fils crutel
désormais au chu de poitiers les flacons
des prêts qui sont enfermés sous clé
dans l'un des réfrigérateurs de la
pharmacie centrale de l'établissement
les trex un médicament qui contient de
l'eau p o
ici entre novembre 97 et juin dernier
d'importantes quantités ont été volés
des flacons comme ceci bien avant le
premier vol
les plex un médicament utilisé pour le
traitement des maladies rénales et de
certains cancers ont été stockés sans
précautions particulières selon la
police c'est l'un des préparateurs du
laboratoire qui aurait subtilisé des
flacons à plusieurs reprises pour
ensuite écoulés ce produit dopant dans
les milieux du cyclisme de la terre tenu
les responsables de l'hôpital ont
renforcé leur surveillance sur les
stocks de la pharmacie et finalement
suspendu le préparateur soupçonné dans
les mots poursuivi il a reconduit les
disparitions malgré le son offre et a
fait de ces produits qui a débouché sur
une extension importante en juin
répondez-nous de points c'est à ce
moment là que l'enquêté diligentée par
les services de police afin de
déterminer celui les policiers de
poitiers ont transmis à leurs collègues
de lille les numéros des lots des prêts
qu'ils volaient au chu actuellement ils
sont comparés avec ceux des flacons
prouvé dans la voiture du soigneur de
l'équipe festina dont l'un des coureurs
est originaire du poitou
une autre équipe que du tour de france
et ce soir dans le collimateur celle de
tvn dont le directeur sportif et le
mettra sont toujours en garde à vue un
mandat d'amener vient d'être délivrée
pour qu'il soit conduit devant un juge
et mise en examen des produits dopants
et des produits masquants ont été
découverts et saisis lors d'une
perquisition dans lequel des pv m ollier
car of holy des galeries
les coureurs de tvm connaîtront-ils le
même sort que ceux de l'équipe festina
sur le plan sportif les organisateurs du
tour de france ne veulent pas se
prononcer pour l'instant sur l'exclusion
éventuelle de cette équipe néerlandaise
j'ai pas eu le temps d'écouter la radio
j'ai pas eu le temps de consulter les
pêches de la fp ce soir sur la sphère tv
m
mais au moment où je vous parle je ne
dispose par conséquent d'aucun élément
nouveau par rapport aux d'aucun élément
complémentaire par rapport au communiqué
que nous avons diffusé ce matin les que
nous avons déposé la salle de presse qui
nous qui nous permettrait de prendre
aucun élément nouveau qui nous
permettrait de prendre une décision
d'exclusion mais sur le plan judiciaire
des éléments nouveaux
ils en marquent la perquisition de
l'hôtel du tvm les hier matin prat selon
le parquet de reims porté ses fruits les
enquêteurs ont retrouvé sur place des
produits dopants et les produits
masquants placé en garde à vue
le directeur sportif et le médecin de
l'équipe ont dû s'expliquer sur ses
trouvailles
tout comme il avait dû le faire
auparavant sur la centaine de doses de
peyo fixé en mars dernier dans une
voiture blick
il ya quelques minutes les deux hommes
ont quitté l'hôtel de police de pamiers
ils devraient être conduits à foix où
est représenté un match deux autres
personnes pourraient être déférés dans
les orchidées
sacré du tour suscite bien sûr toutes
les interrogations toutes les
stipulations le tour 98 menacée comment
réagissent les spectateurs et le milieu
du cyclisme nathalie oisans emmanuel
beck était parmi eux parmi eux sur la
ligne d'arrivée radio qui annonce enfin
le départ de la cour sur les routes
ariégeoises ceux qui attendent le tour
depuis des heures sp d'un mal nécessaire
à un bien
vraiment ce domaine qui croient à la
réalité des choses et des sports le tour
et gâchis et la faute à qui sûrement pas
aux coureurs je pense que les coureurs
ont raison de faire virer tout ça c'est
le problème de l'encadrement qui font
dans les drogues n'est pas des coureurs
d'affaires et si on n'avait pas les
médias pour gonfler ses problèmes de
poids et les plus pessimistes de prédire
déjà la fin du tour
c'est triste fête une fête populaire
c'était c'est comme le mondial c'est
quelque chose de dia international
contre eux dans le monde entier
comment passer les pays étrangers quand
ils vont voir sa compagne la colère des
coureurs c'est désolant
sur la ligne d'arrivée les coureurs ne
sont pas la barre ils ne sont pas les
seuls
mais c'est le problème d'ego ce n'est
pas le mien
je comprends la déception des
découvreurs et les sentiments abandonner
comme ça
les coureurs ont choisi aujourd'hui de
médiatiser leur malaise rien d'étonnant
il au désarroi c'est étendre ce soir à
tout ce qui les entoure
il faut arrêter ce tour écrit ce soir de
notre dans un éditorial notre confrère
le monde qui parle d'un tour de france
discréditer leur poser la question et
marie george buffet ministre de la
jeunesse et des sports
c'est vrai que tous réunis autour de 20
elle apparaît comme très bien d'ailleurs
on peut pas le regarder
regardez peut-être mais ça n'est pas ses
comptes et loi qui supprime m
fidèle de cet événement sportif aux
lettres avec beaucoup de peine
une fois ce tour marqué par sébastien
suis dis que tu es le tour le tour de
même de quoi l'image du dopage
donc si on veut soigner le touriste sur
le retour se terminer ce mieux que toi
ni prochaine prendre tout son sens il
faut noter leur coin de page il faut que
chacun ait le courage sa responsabilité
de simplifier ce fait il faut toujours
une tour redevienne un événement sportif
tout simplement il faut prier pour
continuer ou alors ça voudrait dire
qu'on considère pas a priori personne
participant à ce tour est coupable
d'avoir fait comment ils vont évoluer
moi je crois que le tournoi continue et
puis aussi c'est un des deux côtés
paris quatre doublés c'est pas vrai il
chiffre le contre et on est que personne
aucun sportif de haut niveau ne soit
contrainte à bien à devenir quelqu'un
soit obligée d'avaler des produits pour
tenir informée la solidarité parce que
nous pouvons vous dire pour l'instant
sur ce tour de france nous y reviendrons
de la fin de cette édition
autre sujet le naufrage de perros guirec
les recherches pour retrouver le
plaisancier disparu alors qu'il portait
secours ou scouts en difficulté ont été
abandonnées le drame a donc fait cinq
victimes
le directeur du camp l'abbé cottard
vient d'être présenté au juge
d'instruction qui devrait le mettre en
examen
on lui reproche une accumulation de
négligences graves
olivier sous rémi gousseau nié après une
journée entière de garde à vue l'abbé
jean riffaud tard été déférés peu avant
20h aux côtés de biens dont ils
devraient être mis en examen pour
homicide involontaire avec manquement
délibéré à une obligation de prudence et
de sécurité
un chef d'inculpation particulièrement
grave car le corps de la victoire avait
déjà été inspectée par les services de
la jeunesse et des sports qui l'avait
justement reproché les lacunes de
l'encadrement
l'intéressé a reconnu
je dirais qu'il connaissait parfaitement
cette initiation est que c'est un
technicien qui ne l'a pas appliquée il
ya là de mon point de vue donc
maintenant délibérer est une
circonstance particulièrement grave tôt
ce matin les gendarmes avaient investi
la colonie scouts afin d'interpeller les
responsables défaut d'encadrement et
compétences multiples retards dans le
déclenchement de l'alerté
l'enquêté préliminaire du parquet s'est
en effet révélée accablant pour la déco
tard mais pour son avocat la discipline
de fer qui régnait dans ce tour
devedjian intégristes étaient juste un
choix pédagogique et dago giscou tête
une pédagogie tout à fait particulière
il n'est pas question de faire si aurel
les règles sont respectées ce qu'il ya
c'est une pédagogie qui est tout à fait
particulière et c'est l'encadrement d'un
équipage des enfants entre eux c'est
très important sur la surveillance
adultes ça fait vivre pour elle veut que
les enfants se débrouillent tout seuls
non que les enfants passent débrouille
tout seul mais que les enfants aient une
certaine autonomie pour forger leur
volonté développer leur intelligence au
même moment
selon le rite de 5,5 et aider pour la
chapelle ardente dressée au gymnase de
perros-guirec dans l'assistance outre la
famille et les proches des victimes
de nombreux jeunes issus des mouvances
tout à fait y gardant notre religion les
scouts de france vendeville uniforme et
disons alors ils étaient quand même
quelque chose de cap unique
ce soir les recherches ont été
définitivement abandonnée le drame aura
donc fait trois morts et deux disparus
ce drame vient nous rappeler qu'il
existe une réglementation très stricte
surtout quand il s'agit d'enfants pour
toutes les écoles de voile des
explications dans une école du bassin
d'arcachon avec éric perrin et philippe
dumas y
comme toujours les cours commencent bien
avant d'aller sur l'eau l'instruction
recommandations les moniteurs insiste
toujours sur les consignes de sécurité
dessiné par l'entrée de dents on se
retrouve à la bouée rouge vous attendez
que j'ai démarré mon moteur pour
repartir et ensuite on y va si vite ces
stages obligatoires en dessous de 16 ans
nombre d'encadrants par élève clairement
définis en fonction de l'âge
un arrêté ministériel fixe les règles
minimum mais dans les écoles dépendant
de la fédération française de voile on a
encore durci ce règlement la sécurité
fait partie intégrante de la formation
des moniteurs unification la sécurité
donc les qui comprend
alerte par exemple comme il en revient
tous à la plage ont fait l'effet
d'accomplir doit savoir
c
le musée lapidaire employables pinasse
d'ostréiculteurs vacanciers plaisanciers
le bassin d'arcachon koné ont été des
pointes de trafic
on a donc défini clairement à l'espace
nautique dédié à la voile légère
l'internet fixe et que on peut très
rapidement en cas de problème important
de mobiliser tous les moyens sur un
espace réduit donc d'augmenter
l'efficacité et les moniteurs ne peuvent
sortir de cet espace sans l'autorisation
du chef de base lui seul décide une
éventuelle sortie au large en mettant en
place des moyens plus importants bateau
suiveur fusée de secours et radio hf
tous les enseignants savent que la
rigueur est le prix à payer pour avoir
le plaisir la passion de la mer peut
s'apprendre dès le plus jeune âge
l'humilité face à cet univers également
tout à l'heure sur la côte d'azur et la
provence météo france avait prévenu et
les méditerranéens n'ont pas été déçus
le mercure en folie approché les 40
degrés les services sanitaires sont en
alerte des précautions doivent être
prises notamment pour les bébés et les
personnes âgées
sous la canicule yacine afar berre et
didier beaumont la baie des anges est
écrasée par une chaleur lundi suivi est
élevé pour les peaux sensibles le coup
de soleil arrive après 18 minutes
d'exposition insolation malaise il
secours son bilan mais pas encore
débordés on a été assez chanceux de ne
pas déplorer de gros incidents et donc
nouveau malaise parce que nous sommes en
fin de période de mode juillet les gens
sont plus ou moins acquis mater le vc
bien frais il fait très chaud il faut
boire
cette maison de retraite la canicule est
un ennemi
la plupart des personnes âgées ne sont
pas la chaleur elle n'aime pas boire et
se déshydrate très vite 8 à 10 francs
par jour les aides soignantes propose
des boissons variées
en cas de refus il faut parfois utilisé
quelques vertus si nous arrivons
toutefois défaire le défunt qui fait
c'est un anniversaire et il traîne avec
nous sans pas fermer les yeux pour
apprécier les autres rafraîchissement
l'hydratation extérieur bien accepté par
les pensionnaires à la crèche les petits
effets de cette charge et les
puéricultrices ont plus d'expérience
d'instinct les enfants restent à l'ombre
mais eux aussi sont les premières
victimes de déshydratation
il faut le faire monter rapidement parce
que les mâles idrac est donc tombé dans
le coma et il faut faire très attention
sur le littoral la température est
montée à 34 degrés sous abri une chaleur
encore plus élevées à l'intérieur des
terres et qui va s'installer dans la
semaine à venir les déchets nucléaires
dans un incinérateur d'ordures ménagères
que la découverte pour le moins
surprenant qui était faite ville juste
dans les colonnes villejust qui s'était
déjà rendue célèbre par ses émissions de
dioxyde jose dans la pierre scheidt
rigole
voici la preuve de l'improbable la
découverte par hasard dans les temps
d'un incinérateur d'ordures ménagères de
trac radioactive alors qu'elles n'ont
rien à y faire
feu aux amandiers dans les déchets
calcinés les taux de radioactivité ne
sont pas élevés mais la nouvelle est
inquiétante il est urgent de trouver
l'origine de cette contamination
meurtrier tous ces éléments et puis
ensuite on est conditionné dans une
section spécifique pour faire les
analyses et notamment pour mesurer la
radioactivité dans le laboratoire du
ceva
les chercheurs mènent une enquête depuis
dix jours d'après les premiers résultats
il s'agirait d'un produit de la
recherche nucléaire
c'est pas dangereux du tout quand vous
allez dans le massif central
vous avez aussi des rayonnements
l'élément radioactif ne peut provenir
que d'un laboratoire nous dit-on encore
les étapes à voir lequel nous avons
regardé avec soin à l'intérieur du cera
et nous avons fait nous mène à la
conviction que cela ne vient pas du tout
inquiète les responsables de
l'incinérateur ont demandé un contrôle
de la cité de ceux qui ont été en
contact avec le match qui a contaminé ce
résultat de l'analyse démontré que les
trois agents les plus exposés étaient
indemnes de toute contamination
le prix bas mais aussi la faculté de
retrait le vénéraient fait polytechnique
pour attirer leurs déchets hifti des
déchets ultimes en belgique mais tiers
il était décidé d'installer à l'entrée
un portique de détection radioactives
une première en prendre la politique
avec lionel jospin en visite chez tony
blair dans la circonscription du premier
ministre britannique dans le nord de
l'angleterre les deux hommes voulu
dissiper toutes les rumeurs de désaccord
et afficher clairement l'entente
cordiale qui les unit album it s
décidément il est beaucoup question de
sport ces jours ci or l'actualité même
et quelquefois surtout en politique
tony blair lionel jospin ont voulu
démontrer aujourd'hui qu'il jouait dans
la même équipe une équipe de gauche et
qu'ils étaient prêts à s'afficher
ensemble sur des photos surtout
lorsqu'elle rappelle de récents
événements heureux pour rester dans la
métaphore sportive on pourrait dire que
les deux meneurs de jeu se veulent
complémentaires même si leur style est
différent
les partis différents les pays
différents mais dans les bus les
objectifs on a beaucoup en commun en
particulier avec l exclusion sociale par
exemple je pars que nous sommes en train
de trouver chacun notre propre synthèse
et nous marchons de concerts je crois
que nous nous rapprochons et comme il y
en plus entre nous une amitié
personnelle je crois que cela facilite
le dialogue entre la france et la grande
bretagne
ce rapprochement franco anglaise sera
manifestée de deux façons sur le fond
dans cette circonscription pauvre tony
blair a insisté sur la coloration plus
sociale qu'il donne lippi quelques
semaines à son action sur la forme
ensuite de visites d'églises en aparté
souriant les deux hommes ont voulu
afficher leur entente cordiale et dire
ainsi qu'il n'y a pas entre eux de
compétition
encore un bon chiffre pour le commerce
extérieur français en les cédant 2,14
milliards au mois de mai depuis le début
de l'année le solde positif atteint les
70 milliards une illustration avec le
succès qui se précise pour le tgv à
taiwan une lettre de concessions vient
d'être signé pour la réalisation d'une
ligne reliant le nord au sud de lille
le français alstom et alliée à
l'allemand siemens dans un contrat de 24
milliards pour ce que l'on présente déjà
comme le plus gros chantier du début du
xxième siècle
damien thévenot jean-louis melun
virtuelle cette image le nord et le sud
de taiwan seront alors relié par une
ligne à grande vitesse face au tgv
les 346 kilomètres qui seront engloutis
en une heure et demie au lieu de cinq
actuellement
le projet est gigantesque pour taiwan à
100 milliards de francs
d'investissements il 85000 emplois créés
chaque année je n'ai pas encore signé
mais à la cam et son partenaire allemand
simon devrait être choisi pour fournir
voitures et locomotives
une victoire européenne si on se perd la
place détaille ouais mais je crois qu'il
ya deux facteurs qui ont pesé
le premier une politique de l'andra go
face à la crise générale en asie et
taiwan les moyens parce que taïwan est
moins endettée que ses voisins ensuite
ne pas être victime de ces voisinages
économique ne pas acheter au japon en
particulier montrer qu'on a les moyens
d'acheter en europe montrer à l'europe
on est un partenaire extrêmement
important sur le plan économique les
partenaires extrêmement important pour
elle de messina sans aucun doute à la
quille 45 et cela représente un contrat
de 24 milliards de francs et plusieurs
millions de
travail dans les usines alstom de la
rochelle et du creusot prudente la
direction du groupe préfère attendre la
signature définitive prévue l'année
prochaine pour créer les toits une
heureuse coïncidence
elle a en tout cas appris ce matin que
son tgv était également en très bonne
position pour équiper la future ligne à
grande vitesse mais qu'on verra en outre
il qualifie face à une nouvelle vague
d'émigration 2007 un clandestin ont été
interpellées depuis le début du mois sur
les côtes sud du pays ils sont
originaires d'afrique du kurdistan mais
aussi du kosovo les autorités italiennes
craignent de revivre la grande vague
d'exode des albanais il ya un peu plus
d'un an une correspondance d'alain de
chalon sur des barques de fortune ils
tentent leur chance
une nouvelle vague d'émigration
clandestine frappe à la porte de lille
tél ils sont plus de 2700 depuis le
début du mois
ils viennent d'afrique du nord du
kurdistan et phénomène nouveau du kosovo
via l'albanie toute proche
parfois il se jette à l'eau de façon
être au nom du droit de la mer repêché
par les gardes côtes italiens
qu'importe si c'est dangereux 8
africains se sont ainsi noyer la semaine
dernière mais pour eux le salut passe
par là la plupart ignorent que la loi
italienne a changé qu'ils ne reçoivent
plus de sauf conduit désormais ils sont
placés dans des centres de rétention et
expulsé au bout d'un mois maximum
de gré ou de force
quant aux embarcations elle sacré mais
diablement détruites la plupart déclare
avoir perdu leurs papiers et le pas
savoir d'où ils viennent
ou encore d'avoir de la famille en
italie seule façon de se faire
régulariser
mais rien n'y fait l'italie est entrée
dans schengen et le laxisme au moins
officiellement n'est plus de mise que
l'on craint par dessus tout au ministère
de l'intérieur ici derrière moi c'est
que les événements du kosovo ne provoque
une nouvelle vague d'émigration massive
en provenance d'albanie comme l'italie a
pu en connaître l'an dernier alors ces
nouvelles images de fermeté que l'on a
pu voir ne sont pas destinés seulement à
l'opinion publique italienne est aussi
être vue de l'autre côté de l'adriatique
en albanie un nouveau ministre pour le
nouveau premier ministre pour le japon
qui zemmouchi acte ministre des affaires
étrangères a été désigné par son parti
majoritaire pour diriger le prochain
gouvernement et résoudre la crise
économique qui secoue le pays
les marchés ne paraissent pas rom ont
convaincu puisque le yen a fortement
chuté
retour en france avec un successeur pour
aimé jacquet c'est son adjoint roger
lemerre qui devrait prendre lundi le
relais comme sélectionneur national de
l'équipe de france deux autres candidats
possibles jean tigana et d'irun ont pu
se libérer de leur club
christelle bertand au petit jeu des
pronostics
roger lemerre a la plus grosse cote 4h30
au poster des besoins sélectionneur est
le successeur naturel dit me jacques
lemaire nomme de l'ombre connaît bien
les joueurs et il fait l'unanimité à la
fédération une fédération qui tarde
pourtant à prendre cette décision et qui
a contacté d'autres candidats et jean
tigana actuel entraîneur de monaco est
encore sous contrat
à quinze jours du début du championnat
le président du club monégasque jean
louis campora n'a pas bien tout
l'intention de laisser partir tigana
guy vous autres prétendants a déclaré
forfait en expliquant dans un communiqué
qu'il n'avait pas pu se libérer de ses
obligations avec la violer à moins d'un
revirement soudain ranger le maire
devrait donc être des grumiers
officiellement lundi nouveau
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
le nerf ancien footballeur professionnel
a commencé sa carrière d'entraîneur en
1975 il lui aussi est champion du monde
avec l'équipe de france militaire
juste derrière aimé jacquet roger
lemerre va se retrouver sur le devant de
la scène pour un jour voilà en reste
avec l'équipe de france champion du
monde mais avec un petit voyage en
kabylie à l'est de l'algérie avec des
moon où elle n'est le père de zinédine
zidane et où toute sa famille n'est pas
peu fier du chief prodigue gérard dhesse
bec et jean-françois renou il fait le
pèlerinage
depuis on se passionne pour les dominos
depuis toujours les cafés le lieu de
rencontre pour les hommes mais ici au
café des repères on affiche les origines
les kabyles vives sig avant l'arrivée
des arabes
lila dossier on est dans le village d'à
que moule coincé entre les montagnes à
500 mètres d'altitude un village devenu
célèbre depuis quelques semaines la
maison des gitanes et bien modeste
c'est ici qu'est né le père de zinédine
avant d'émigrer en france dans les
années 50 pour trouver un travail
comme beaucoup de capitaux la tante du
footballeur ne parle que de lui l'avenir
est connu tout petit mon père est venu
avec toute la famille pour la serbie
puis il a laissé pour les études qu'on
joue au ballon rond ne voulait pas il
leur a dit je veux faire pour lui et
descendez vers le père retourne chaque
année au village mais zinedine n'est pas
revenue depuis douze ans il jouait alors
dans l'équipe régionale et sa tante
avait déjà peur pour le championnat je
ne regarde pas je n'aime pas aller là
bas toute une région la kabylie tout un
pays l'algérie aimerait bien que leur
héros puisse revenir un jour ici on
imagine l'accueil qui lui serait réservé
mais est-ce que zinedine zidane on a
vraiment envie at il encore les yeux
tournés vers l'algérie
ce n'est pas sûr et dans ce cas est bien
ce serait la rançon d'une intégration
réussie
le radeau de la méduse vous connaissez
sans doute le célèbre tableau de
géricault inspiré d'un tragique naufrage
survenu en 1816 le radeau de la méduse
est aujourd'hui un film qui a bien
failli lui aussi fernique rage puisque
son réalisateur l'a porté à bout de bras
au milieu des déboires pendant plus de
treize ans pascal deschamps car l'on
rencontre
retour sur un fait divers tragique et un
site avant le naufrage du titanic a lui
aussi marqué toute une époque
un événement créé hanté pendant plus de
trente ans le réalisateur iradj azimi
d'où son petit appartement parisien qui
lui sert de bureau restent les souvenirs
douloureux de tournage ou de son film a
tout connu du cyclone hugo à la
frilosité des distributeurs qu'est ce
que ce jour de décembre 97 plus couple
et même devant le ministère de la
culture pour que son film sorte à pain
nous ne demandions pas de faveur ni de
subventions nous demandions selon la
justice robert un film français
et c'est cet acte et monaco et c'était
un appel à la justice grâce à donner
coup pouce le film est donc aujourd'hui
sur les écrans aux spectateurs de cet
hommage un épisode occulté de notre
histoire en juin 1816 embarque sur la
méduse des hommes que tout sépare way
you lie et bonaparte après le naufrage
le commandant répartir lui très rarement
les partisans du roi sur les canaux et
les autres sur un radeau de fortune
avant de couper les amarres
c'était une aventure extraordinaire
savané juste après le waterloo et il y
aurait la résidence de l'otello de la
france de l'époque déjà sur la frégate
est une parmi les gens est une des idées
des tumultes d'action c'est une forme
très vibrante des 140 nous sommes
condamnés à dériver 14 seulement
reviendront vivant le temps que jerry
qu'on s'en inspire en de leur réussite
pour immortaliser leurs souffrances en
un hymne à l'égalité une oeuvre
dérangeante qu'il aura bien du mal à
faire exposer une oeuvre forte
il faisait entrer le fait divers au
musée la disposition des escales pexiora
dos au moment du sauvetage
pouvez vous m'aider
le radeau de la méduse abondent les
séries nouveau moment de vérité et même
si certains peuvent le trouver un peu
long il est l'oeuvre sans compression
d'un réalisateur ont été qui aura mis
treize ans à faire le film de ses rêves
rolling stones l'éternel retour au moins
de quinze jours après la finale du
mondial le stade de france s'apprêtait à
accueillir le plus célèbre grotte le
groupe europ du monde pour un concert
unique en france après 36 années de
scène mick jagger et les papys du rock
ont toujours la pêche comme l'ont
constaté louis carzou et bruno l'hiver
touche les clameurs du reporter champion
du monde dont à peine eu le temps de
s'éteindre que le pack de france
s'apprête à résonner au rythme des
bolides et les quinquagénaires du rock
emmené par mick jagger et keith richards
n'ont pas lésiné sur les moyens
une sono 2 252 bill watts une scène de
plus de 50 mètres de l'eau le tour mené
par 10 buts et 66 canon en plus jeunes
bonnet record cela assure le responsable
français du coup là il y en avait
beaucoup d'appréhension avant de surtout
de par le fait que le lieu était quand
même très pris par le mondial n'a pas
été question avant au niveau d'un
spectacle puisqu'on a le premier
spectacle en fait du stade de france
donc essuyé les plâtres sera peu des
fois avoir beaucoup d'inconvénients pour
le moment je touche du bois mais on voit
plutôt un avantage qui devrait
accueillir demain soir les quelques 88
tron s'est vu sans oublier bien sûr leur
groupe de rock préférés
la musique encore de la musique un peu
partout cet été dans les festivals en
france mais aussi chez nos voisins comme
à nyon en suisse où le paléo festival
vient de fêter sa 23e édition et son
deux millionième spectateur en haut de
la fiche le chanteur eagle eye cherry
olivier les lula frédéric établi
non
un côté chaleureux de folk et de blues
venus du nord qui rafraîchit les
milliers de visiteurs du paléo festival
de nyon
une pop limpide servi en europe ce
barrage une âme de 29 ans est lui dans
son pays la suède meilleur artiste de
l'année
de fait
mais
la musique c'est qu'on ne peut pas la
décrire
elle n'est pas palpable nous entendait
de la musique mais vous ne savez pas
toujours d'où elles viennent parfois la
musique et magie
parfois elle peut faire peur elle peut
d'être agressif
un premier album est déjà un tube eagle
eye cherry a placé kipré jeunesse à new
york entre l'école d'art dramatique et
les clubs de jazz il fréquentait en
compagnie de son père de chuck célèbre
trompettiste de jazz
il a litres mais la chose la plus
importante que mon père m'a apprise
c'est de savoir qui je suis de savoir
cela quelle est la voie que je dois suis
mon père était professeur il disait à
ses élèves d'être humaine the noise in
pé miles davis et john coltrane
j'ai suivi ma voix mon album reflète ma
personnalité à 99,9 pour cent
m
un papa jazzman une demi-soeur neneh
cherry devenue l'égérie durable eagle ae
lui a choisi une autre voie celle du hip
hop aux harmonies l'ailier prouver le 6
mai une musique nous invite à flâner le
temps d'un été
le temps d'une tournée à travers
l'europe
voilà avant de nous quitter retour pour
le tour de france avec qik suite que des
images qui viennent le demi pas retenir
les quatre responsables de l'équipe
faits réels et les lois sont arrivés au
palais de justice de fois ils seront
déférés au parquet et présenté au juge
dans les jours qui viennent
voilà nous parvient à également en
interview de laurent brochard de
l'équipe festina laurent brochard le
champion du monde en titre laurent
brochard qui a été libéré après avoir
avoué qu'il s'était effectivement dopé
il écoute on ne pas couper du team
system bon choses et je pense qu'elle
fait ou leur a certainement nous a sorti
du tour exclu du tour ces erreurs nous
empêcher de travailler déjà en prison
voilà qu'est ce que vaut ce qu'on sache
pas que je n'ai jamais été contrôlé
positif de l'équipe donc lui et moi
j'amène un contexte comme l'emploi donc
ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire
peut-être il faut donc moins rapproché
voilà on retrouve maintenant sur le tour
au cap d'agde de florent peu trop pour
faire un dernier point sur la situation
sur l'ambiance dans le tour au terme
d'une journée complètement folle florent
c'est une journée incroyable une journée
qui restera dans les annales parce que
je peux vous dire qu'il sait on a tout
simplement cru que le tour allait
s'arrêter au moins l'espace d'une
journée
il a fallu toute la persuasion des
dirigeants du tour pour convaincre les
coureurs de remettre de son armée
française ce matin
quand on était à tarascon pourquoi les
coureurs sont partis parce qu'on peut se
demander pourquoi ils sont pas allés au
bout de leur action d'abord pour le
public pour le respect du public ce
public qui les soutient depuis le début
on avait vu notamment au moment des
affaires festina et puis il faut
souligner y avait pas une totale
solidarité dans ce peloton puisque
certains comme jan ullrich voulait
partir ce matin et d'autres au contraire
comme jalabert a et luc leblanc voulait
s'arrêter et cette absence de stars et
était d'ailleurs regretté par de
nombreux coureurs
c'est un événement qui a ébranlé le tour
qui a ébranlé la direction du tour vous
allez l'entendre dans les propos de
jean-marie leblanc c'était à la
conférence de presse tout à l'heure que
si les avait été annulée le tour 98
compromettrait peut-être pas il était
sûr non plus qu'il fallait peut être
dépassé le stade de la colère bien
complet possible l'avez compris c'est un
choc pour tout le monde et sera le seul
décor on le pressentait depuis quelques
jours un ras-le-bol généralisé et nous
mêmes nous le ressentons car les corps
et maintenant ne veulent plus nous
répondre
la plupart des courants ne veulent pas
nous répond est sur le bord des routes
le public commence à prendre à partie
les journalistes commencent à nous
prendre pour cible en quelque sorte
parce que vous le savez les coureurs
m'ont dit depuis longtemps que la presse
était à l'origine de tous leurs maux
alors demain les coureurs se réuniront
ils avaient prévu cette réunion ce soir
même
la ferons demain matin et ils prendront
position par rapport à l'union cycliste
internationale et aussi par rapport à la
presse puisque la presse et selon le
responsable de beaucoup de leurs
problèmes
aujourd'hui mais vous l'avez compris le
coeur n'y est plus vraiment chez les
coureurs comme chez les suiveurs
hier c'est florent mothe rose ce journal
est terminé merci d'avoir suivi dans un
instant la météo de laurent romejko je
vous retrouve avec plaisir demain à 20h
bonne soirée